Factoriza "r" cuadrada más 4r menos 45.
Y aunque yo sé que esto es fácil de factorizar
por otros métodos
quiero seguir factorizando
por agrupación
y recuerda
que para factorizar por agrupación
lo primero que hay que fijarnos
es en 2 números tales que multiplicados me den
el coeficiente que está al lado de la "r" cuadrada y el coeficiente libre, es decir,
"a" por "b",
me tiene que dar 1 por -45,
1 por -45 es -45,
y por otra parte
la suma de estos mismos números "a" más "b"
me tienen que dar
el coeficiente que está al lado de la "r".
"a" más "b" tiene que ser
igual a 4, muy bien.
Y ahora voy a buscar 2 números
que su multiplicación me dé -45
y que su suma dé 4.
¿Qué número puedo pensar en ellos?
y bueno lo que quiero que veas
es que no quiero tomar números muy grandes
o muy alejados entre sí,
porque 45 por ejemplo,
se puede factorizar en 45 y 1
pero, 45 y 1
están muy lejos,
su diferencia nunca me va a dar 4,
entonces me voy a tomar dos números
más cercanos entre sí, tal vez,
3 y 15,
no, me sirve más
9 y 5,
9 y 5 creo que son los números bastante cercanos,
los cuales nos pueden dar el valor de 4
si nosotros los sumamos
o los restamos.
Así que voy a tomarme el 5 positivo
y después el 9 negativo, y
si te das cuenta
5 por -9 me da -45
y si me tomo la sumam
me va a quedar
5 menos 9,
lo cual me da -4,
que no es 4 pero si
yo le cambió el signo a estos dos números,
es decir en - 5 y 9,
esto sí me va a dar 4
4 positivo y perfecto.
Entonces ya tengo mis dos números tales
que multiplicados me dan -45
y sumados me dan 4,
por lo tanto, ahora voy a romper esta expresión
y la voy a poner
de la siguiente manera.
En lugar de poner 4r,
vamos a poner,
-5r y 9r.
Así que déjame ponerlo aquí,
esto lo voy a escribir como
9r menos 5r
este de aquí es lo que voy a romper
de este trinomio
para que
yo lo pueda factorizar por agrupación.
Mientras que por otra parte tenemos
"r" cuadrada -45 al final y bueno,
como factorizamos por agrupación
nos fijamos
en los primeros dos términos
y de aquí vamos a factorizar
lo más que podamos
es decir, de estos primeros dos términos me va a quedar "r" que multiplica a "r" más 9,
es lo más que se puede factorizar,
"r" por "r" me queda "r" cuadrada,
"r" por 9 me queda 9r,
y después
de estos otros dos términos
voy a factorizar lo más que se pueda,
que es un -5,
-5 que multiplica
a "r" en primer lugar
- 5r entre -5
me va a dar "r"
y después tengo -45  entre -5,
lo cual me da 9 positivo,
más 9,
y entonces ya tengo
esta expresión que tengo aquí,
y me doy cuenta que "r" más 9
es mi factor común,
por lo tanto como es factor común,
lo voy a factorizar de nuevo,
y me va a quedar algo
de la siguiente manera.
"r" más 9 que multiplica a su vez a
"r" menos 5,
"r" más 9 multiplica tanto a "r",
date cuenta en esta parte de aquí.
Y por otra parte multiplica -5
que es
esta otra parte que tengo aquí,
por lo tanto,
de resultado me va a quedar,
"r" más 9 por "r" -5.